the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so what I would like to discuss today is
just touch upon what kind of problems
the quantitative analysts are solving in
the commodity world the problems that
are somewhat different from the other
markets and I'm sure you have the whole
year of lectures here from people in
from different markets and you will
judge for yourself that the models were
building somewhat if not completely
different so and this is my goal today
is just for you to have some tastes of
what kind of models we are looking at so
let's start
let's start with with the following
abstract from the dow jones publication
The Dispatch which announced in 2009
that the traffic girl which is the
biggest trader
one of the biggest commodity and energy
trader is potential on track to post his
best results ever in fiscal 2009 on
lower oil prices in contango markets
remember 2008 just a year before that
the oil prices shot to the highest
possible level two hundred fifty nine
dollars per barrel and a lot of people
blame the traders for for the high oil
prices and yet in 2008 when the prices
dropped in 2009 I'm sorry next year when
the prices dropped to $30 per barrel as
a remember to the lowest possible level
that that we remember Trafigura is about
to make the biggest profit ever so it
sounds like a contradiction so they're
making money on the low oil prices and
can't anger and contango have to explain
to you what it is i assume that
everybody here knows what futures what
the futures contract is if not just let
me know and I will explain I mean just
it's very simple concept but so don't be
shy and just tell me so I would like to
show you how Trafigura will make the
record profit in the year when the
prices are at the record low level but
they are in contango
so this is the graph of futures
contracts futures prices oil futures
prices on January 15 s 2009 futures
contract is simply the contract that
allows you to buy today a let's say in
January the contract the I'm sorry the
barrel of oil for delivery in some
future time that's all
you always know what the price will be
by looking into Wall Street Journal
right section C open you will see if you
want to delay you have delivery in
August the price will be around what 55
dollars if you want delivery of the on
February of next year rights of February
2010 the price will be $60 if you want
delivery now the price will be $35 so if
you want to buy it's basically the spot
price there is no four for your
knowledge there is no spot price as such
and whatever you see on CNBC for example
on TV when they give you the spot price
of all it's it's the price of the first
future contracts of this one of the
nearby the most nearby futures country
so as you can see this is the curve and
we call that the curve is in contango if
the price is monotone increasing if
they're decreasing it's called the
quotation that's all so just a useful
term for you to know so at that time
January 15th
the price is indeed we're monotone
increasing they're going from 35 to
February into $60 in favor so this is
February of 2009 this is February 2010
as you can see the prices were going
from 35 to $60 so let's now see how
traffic aura made money
can you guess by the way yes
exactly
so that's precisely what they've done
what what is needed for that though
there is one little thing that's
required you this price is the ability
to buy right but you need a little bit
more you need I'm sorry no no you login
you bought at thirty five storage you
need the storage you need to be able to
wait one year because you already sold
at $60 next year right and very so you
looked in a massive profit off so this
is your strategy just borrow 35 buy one
barrel store it then immediately it
sells or short means just go and sell
the one barrel for next year at $60 so
you have you made $25 I'm sorry you made
$25 just on commodity you have to
unfavorable get this 20 February next
year you will get this $25 you'll pay
the interest which will be maybe let's
say 10% so it's it will be 3.5 dollars
so you made total profit $21 if like
Trafigura you have 5060 million barrels
of storage you can easily calculate how
much money they have without any risk
they made at this particular yeah so
whenever you hear the traders are
benefiting from the high prices it's not
actually if the same stations existed in
the high prices then the interest will
be substantially lower they can drop
their profit by 50% if let's say the
same where at the price is hundred
twenty five to 130 135 260 right you
would have the enormous interest payment
so in reality you need the low prices
but they'd like to have a contango we
really don't care prices low high so so
to summarize we need to
have I mean just little thing here that
the strategy works like a charm the only
thing you need a storage okay let me now
invert the question let me ask you this
question let's say we have the same
curve where January we are on January
1st 2009 and we are asked to get the
storage you want to have your boss's
colonies and is saying I mean I need
storage all sorts from August to
December right so in August we have the
prices about 55 dollars in December $58
you go and get me here's your credit
card all right let me just go and get it
well storage is usually you get it at
the auction so a lot of people come to
the auction and they'll bid so now
you're going with the boss's credit card
right well you have the following
dilemma if you want if you borrow too
little right you will never get it if
you bid too much you will have the
winners curse namely you will never be
able to recover the money that you paid
for that storage so you have to have
before you bid you have to have a plan
how do you or strategy how do you
recover the money that you pay for the
storage through some foolproof riskless
activity some strategy like Trafigura
remember they have the riskless strategy
they lock in the profit they can go to
sleep for a year and then vacation and
then come back and get this profit back
how do you in this particular case you
have whenever you bid something you also
have to have a plan in mind how to
recover this money and even more to get
a little bit of profit so my question to
you
you need storage for from August to
December how much would it bid
these are the prices if you need more
prices they're all here so you need the
storage from August to December
so how much would you bid for the
storage you don't have the storage so
you have to when you get it then you do
what you maybe you what we did before
because before but we did assume that we
already have it right now you don't but
if you win it you will have it but if
you win it you have to have the strategy
how to recover this money
yes well it's not because remember you
are competing against other people right
so if you go it become too greedy they
will outbid you if you let's say bid one
penny right assuming that you'll make so
they won't beat it so should be what is
the highest you can bid huh you say
three dollars three all right give me
the strategy that recovers us three
dollars you don't have to borrow because
it's futures contract you don't need
just you just go long
they August so by August using the
futures contract and sell December using
the futures contract you don't even need
to borrow money you will need to borrow
maybe when you got get to August right
then when you have to pay $55 then
you'll borrow right so you you bid three
dollars you recover three dollars no
profits Oprah most likely you will be
299 right that's the highest from
leaking gold you have to give yourself
at least a penny after a profit right
I'm sorry let's let's forget about
interest for a moment just for for
simplicity in reality of course you
never should forget about it but in
order not to make our discussions too
complicated no interest so you basically
will be $2.99 and seems to me right you
get the penny of profit and you have a
strategy forget the storage you know
what to do you immediately go by August
using futures country by August and so
December looking in $3.00 right pay
$2.99 if you manage to win if everybody
is not as smart as you are and just be
something that's all maybe they want
bigger profit you will win the storage
you will look in okay and if everybody
agrees right this is actually a standard
strategy and people used at all
time right understand that's what I
would call that's what the trader would
do it that's kind of the trader it's a
business guy would do that I mean just
this is a common strategy was very very
common let's say in the nineties
what the quant will do and that's where
the added value of the quant is to the
organization they will do something
completely different
what they will do they will on January
1st they will sell something that is
called August December spread option
you've heard the word option right often
is characterized by the payout at
expiration so we have expiration we have
the payout this is not your typical
options not like IBM option this is
something different
the payout is determine at expiration
which is let's say July 31st right
before the beginning of August right you
will look again at the New York Times or
Wall Street Journal and look at the
prices December and August prices right
on July 31st and if the difference is
positive this little plus sign means
that if it's positive then you pay a to
the owner of the option this difference
if it's negative you pay zero right you
are more familiar with the with the
options where one of this thing is just
a fixed strike it's called this fixed
right here there is no strike it's
simply the difference between December
and August contract right but it's a two
dimensional object so it's a little bit
more complicated to value it but there
is the whole methodology developed the
same way for the regular analysis for
the spread options so the the quant will
sell this production on August 1st why
is it better why is it better well first
of all you have to we have to discuss
how much will I get for this option
when I sold it I give it to you just for
you to be confident that I'm not trying
to deceive you or anything like that you
will get this is the formula that is
used to compute the value of that option
and when I substitute it all the
parameters that are necessary I get that
the value of the option is 447 so I
immediately on January first got 447
everybody else is going ready to bid $3
I have in my pocket 447 I can bid let's
say 420 right guaranteed if I know that
everybody else is bidding 30 I will win
the storage plus my profit margin is not
a penny anymore my profit margin is 27
cents right if I I can do even for 10
right even increase my profit margin if
I really want to be greedy in this
particular case but clearly I can have a
bigger margin I can have a bigger bet
you can guess by the way without even
looking at the formula why the value of
this option with the payout like this
with this payout why is it bigger than
$3 it's always bigger than $3 no forget
about again interest rates it's not the
discount what is the engineer first what
is the intrinsic value if there is no
volatility at all then the intrinsic
value of the option so that zero
volatility the value of the option is
exactly the difference between December
and August on January 1st which is three
dollars so three dollars in three is the
intrinsic value of that option and we
all know that the value of the option is
greater than it trans equality if there
is a volatility because there is a
volatility of the value is greater than
three dollars and actually it's
substantially greater than three dollars
because the volatility in the energy
markets is very high it's much much
higher than what we see in the interest
rates or affects why
in this area let's we'll get to that you
are you asking exactly the correct
question because yes I'm proud
I got 447 I paid for 20 I mean that was
billion for 20 of course I won right I
got my storage I bring him back home now
let's see what kind of risk I brought
home I have 27 cents in my pocket left
right it's my profit but now let's
assume on July 31st let's say December
price goes to 8 dollars and the August
price goes to I don't know $55 I sold
this option how much do I owe on July
31st right option is exercised how much
do I owe to the owner of the option if
December 1 July 31st is 80 and the
August is 55 mm yes $25 its I have only
27 cents in my pocket right so what I do
how do we that's my risk as you tell me
this is the risk that all of a sudden I
owe astronomical amount of money to the
person to whom I sold this option so
they do do Iran to Venezuela or whatever
gesture now where what dirt can I get
remember I have a storage and on July
31st dogus price is 60 55 and the
December is 80 so you already told me
what to do in this situation that's what
traders would do I mean they would buy
immediately the August at 55 immediately
sell December because I have the storage
now I can extract this $25 using my
physical asset so this is the beauty of
the physical or real options that I can
buy doing certain things I can extract
the payout of the option so I'm
completely protected
so my it seems to me that my storage and
that spread option is the same thing
right because I'm fully hedged with my
storage right I mean just is that clear
they understand how I managed to escape
terrible predicament yes yes it's an
auction right so I received 447
everybody beats $3 or $2.99 and then 420
right there is no value of the storage
except for the value what people are
bidding for it is that's it so if I my
bid is the highest that's it I received
it so is that your question are you
asking me something else
oh you were talking about what happens
if vice versa December not goes to 80
but to $20 right and this one still
remains at 55 I do nothing because I the
payout of the option is equal to zero
because this difference is negative
right so I oh nothing to the value to
the O to the owner of the option and I
do nothing where is my storage it's a
fully hedged proposition so the storage
and this option is one and the same
okay any questions so conceptually we're
on the same page right okay so that was
of course the character of the real
situation so reality is slam but more
complicated as always in reality let's
say I go and bid for two years right I
mean just I need the storage for two
years
there are many spread options I can sell
right right in the in this my example
again in the character example has sold
August December but I could have sold
August November or boost October right
oh I can sell if I have for two years I
can same a number June September and so
on there if I have two years it's 24 you
can understand how many options I can
sell right I mean just options where
options to put the oil into the tank
today and extract it six months later
with some profit or maybe three months
later and so there are a lot of this
option so first of all I have to
determine so I can sell a lot of these
options against the storage I have to
determine a what is the most valuable
portfolios options I can sell against
the story
this is with this kind of our strategist
starts shaping up so we want to optimize
something and what about optimizing we
optimizing the value of the portfolio
that they can sell against the storage
value is remember this cache that I get
from selling the option I want to get
not just 447 I want to get 447 hundred
thousand I don't know just whatever me
just say I have to I want to maximize
and bring it to the highest possible
level based on the information price
information volatility information that
exists at this particular moment I want
to determine what what kind of portfolio
options now this is the optimization
what are the constraints and now the
constraints requiring that you have some
technical contractual and legal and the
environmental understanding what's going
on for simplest constraints that could
give you is that you cannot put the gas
in the ground or oil in the tank as
quickly as you want right there is
certain constraints on the injection
rate there are certain constraints on
the withdrawal rate it you cannot
instantaneously extract gas from the
ground or oil from the tank you can
never have a situation remember that
whenever the option expires you have to
do something to extract remember if to
extract the value when whenever you all
somebody the option holder fifteen
dollars or twenty five dollars you had
to put the oil in the tank wait six
months extracted under no circumstances
so your option portfolios should be sold
in such a way against the storage that
under no circumstances you are in the
situation when the option is in the
money so option is positive you have to
do something to extract the value so you
have to inject and there is no space
because you've done something before
because some other options expired
before and you
pootle ready all in the tank and the
tank is full and now a new option
expires and tells you put more into the
tank and there is no space in the
opposite situation when you need to sell
from the tank and the tank is empty
because some other options from the
portfolio managed to take completely
deplete the oil from the tank questions
so let's try make an attempt to write
this optimization problem just for fun
so this you have an idea what's going on
so first of all let's see what we are
trying to optimize the let's start from
the end this country simply tells me
that I want at some particular F is the
price of the futures contract if
exploration will say months of June so
this particular term of the sum tells me
that how much I will have to pay in June
if I buy this is the volume if I buy
let's say right now is January if I bind
you in June this amount of oil right
using my futures contract how much I
have to pay this is kind of cash from my
pocket right it's clear right the same
thing there is no optionality here it's
just straightforward buying and selling
buying into the storage and for selling
from the storage agreed a little bit
more complicated is this beast I mean
just this is the option as I told you
before the option that injects oil into
the tank at one month and extracted in
months I and extract it in the month J
which is later so you extract in June
extract a November right this is the
value of
from this is the volume associated with
this option I solved this option
therefore I have the positive cash flow
all right so this is 447 in my pocket
this is another option that I solved
this is option which is kind of opposite
which is first you extract them you
inject which is typical situation when
you receive your storage was already oil
in the tank right the curve is not
contango but backwardation
so it's more profitable for you to sell
it now because the prices are high and
then replace it later so it's over it's
kind of symmetric situation to this one
to the options that we already discussed
it's just it works when the the curve is
in the opposite direction right so you
try to make money no matter how just the
new prices look you're trying to make
this money so you try to optimize this
portfolio okay now now let's talk about
constraints to determine the constraints
I introduced right now the variable
boolean variable which is 1 or 0 which
basically tells me if when I come to the
exercise of this option like in our case
on July 31st in our first example and I
see if the option is in the money or not
so do I have to do something or not
do you have to inject into the storage
and so is it $15 or it's - $15 if it's -
$15 the difference between the prices I
don't do anything so then at 0 if it's
plus 15 I have to do something - because
the owner of the option asks me $15
right and so I have to put all into the
tank and extract it sometimes later so
that's one the same thing with the
option which is opposite first with the
first withdrawal down injection
so then injection constraints will be
quite simple so at the expiration I look
if this one is one right then it means
that I have to do something and what I
have to do I have to inject at the mall
at the months I I have to inject this
volume X I J right which was boobie was
drawn later so that is injection if some
option before that was in the - oh I
have to inject before and withdraw now
that will cancel my injection so if
simultaneously I have to injection
because one option is in the money and
withdrawal because the option that was
exercised before isn't the money they
kind of cancel each other right so
that's why this sign is plus and minus
the same thing with others options and
the same thing with pure futures
contract and that should be less than
the injection rate the same thing with
withdrawal rate right I mean just it's
it's a similar consideration now maximum
capacity constrains it tells me that if
I start with the this inventory in my
tank at time 0 and this is basically how
much I will get at any time I for any
months I that's how much I will have in
my tank by that time I you have to
believe me because it's not a trivial
thing but the same thing with minimum
cancer it's what you really have to
understand that I'm known that X Y Z V
and the unfortunately Omega is also
unknown Omega is just even though it's
basically these are the volumes this is
the kind of control variable the price
right and the the price can be this the
spread can be positive can be negative
can be zero right and this is becoming a
very ugly nonlinear problem very quickly
very big so you have a lot of variables
right I mean for two years you have what
12 times 11 which is kind of 32 right
and I just know 24 I'm sorry it's 24
times 23 so it's 12 10 20 30 so it's
it's a big it's a big number of
variables plus plus equal a big number
of constraints and the constraints are
nonlinear so the problem is pretty hard
I leave it up to you to decide how to
solve it that's why I take an
optimization courses here I can suggest
that there are several approaches people
would take there is approximation where
this problem is approximated let's say
by linear programming or quadratic
programming or whatever you want right
you can do it through Monte Carlo
simulations or there is an interesting
approach through the stochastic control
I recommend you a paper by Carmona and
loot Kowski exactly how to how to do
this how to make a decision of injecting
or withdrawn our based on the stochastic
control of stochastic optimization
methodology right but it is quite an
interesting paper so either this
approaches can be used and they are used
and give you sometimes different results
but you can leave any questions so far
they were this way
none of this solutions is better or
prettier whatever because of the
parameters they go to the problem and
you can have the most precise
methodology but if your parameters are
only fifty percent accurate right in
reality I mean just all those parameters
necessary for Monte Carlo simulations of
stress control you really don't know
what they are which is can only can
guess through some implied market
parameters like volatility and so on and
if you're wrong you're wrong
even your method can be absolutely
precise I like it because it's really
very nice mathematics there would person
who don't do that I'm not going to tell
you what we are using right but we do
something different and our methodology
is chosen to be robust
let me just we chose it because we want
mr. Roche to be extremely robust so we
want we don't want small changes we
don't want to have the station when
small changes which usually comes when
you over parameterize I mean people like
to go and later to I mean in the second
half I will discuss some of the models
people use for example they these see
the richness of the behavior of the
prices and they want to introduce a lot
of parameters to capture this regions by
that they sacrifice the stability and
robustness so little changes in the
parameters and the value can change
substantially so we prefer a different
approach where we may be sacrifice some
of the value but we will gain the
Buster's stability and this'll be the
most important thing and most
importantly everything that we use in
the model can be verified by the outside
regulators and controllers which is this
day and age is extremely important don't
because these days to have a model that
is calibrated even the word calibrated
causes a lot of antennas just going up
so try not to calibrate anything every
sin that we do can be verified every
little brick that goes to the model can
be traded in the market can be verified
that's this is very very important in
this day and age yes we'll get to that
but very quick answer is this I'm just
to have a lot of parameters in the model
right I mean I'll show you some of the
models people use these parameters are
not you don't see them in the market
it's the result of your model right it's
because you chose this particular model
right somebody black Scholes uses one
parameter if you use black Scholes with
jump diffusion term and some other you
introduce another ten parameters these
parameters are not observable so you
have to somehow calibrate it to the some
market data and the calibration become
in a pretty interest because calibration
usually is done through some kind of
least squares approach so you try to
look at the observable data and then
adjust your parameters using some least
squares approach to match that data this
least squares is notoriously bad problem
so if you even have many solutions the
solution set can be very flat so you can
stop very early I mean just there are
problems with least squares it's
nonlinear optimization so by itself it's
a very difficult so calibration can be
very very unstable anymore okay
now I have to tell you the secret there
is no Santa Claus right let me just
remember I was telling you that I go and
I sold the option right to get for 47
right I got off in reality there is no
option market there is no nobody will
buy this option for me the market for
this option nonexistent now what do we
do in this particular situation well
that's where the whole beauty of black
Scholes come to play right mean black
Scholes didn't get the the novel price
for integrating some very simple player
function right that you can do in first
year of school right let me just they
got the Nobel Prize and all the way get
kind of appreciation for they've done
because they show that with this value
they don't also have the strategy that
allows you by doing something every day
or every half day you can replicate this
value so if you paid for the option $5
right then you can show how to what to
do every day right they tell you what to
do every day in order to get back this
five dollars at the end right so that's
what their main achievement or if I sold
an option right and received five
dollars right I mean just then I will do
something that I will use this five
dollars to replicate any payout I all at
the answer I sold it to you for example
so the end I owe you $50 but they showed
how through the dynamic hedging they can
and using these five dollars that I
receive upfront I can be able to meet my
obligations to you so they showed how to
replicate the payout of the option so in
reality I don't have to have the market
running if I sold somebody an option for
47 I don't have to have anybody who buys
it what I will do I will simply use this
dynamic hedging strategy
Scholz advised me adapted to the spread
options right which at the end will
produce for me 447 that's it I mean the
result but here again this is another
task that Kwan's will have to do not
only they will find the value they will
produce every day the strategy that
allows you to extract this for 40 cents
so we've already showed what to do with
the storage but now you have to do on
the next level a right of complexity you
have to do they tell to the trader what
to do every day in order in reality get
this 447 from selling this option so you
solve this you told this trader I'm
selling this portfolios
$400,000 right for the storage but he
said but there is no nobody to sell it
and you'll sell don't worry I will do it
through dynamic hedging at the end you
will get two hundred thousand dollars so
he will believe you and then he will do
it he will get hundred thousand then on
the next level you have to work with the
guy who operates the storage and we will
tell that person went to inject oil and
went to withdraw and to get all this
magic that we've discussed before so I
think it will be a very logical point
for me right now to stop and in the next
half will discuss how to model the power
plant so we're going to the next topic
so you have so so far we have covered
how to model a physical asset right name
storage the same approach can be used to
model practically everything that we're
interested in for example we can use the
same thing to model the the tankers
power plants this is storage refined
there is anything and we just power line
pipelines everything can be modeled
using this
the origin of course the nature of the
beast will be different right and you
have to understand the nuances and the
as I said the constraints of every I
mean this modeling for example tanker
requires understanding of the all the
routes and adjust the constraints in the
ports and and all these things but but
the conceptual philosophical approach is
the same you have to find some
optionality and add some additional
reading so I obviously don't have time
to go over the whole thing
but let's again for you to have a taste
of this I mean just let's decide how to
model the powerplant assume that you are
the manager of the merchant power plant
merchant means that you decide when to
run - not right you you run it to
maximize the profit of this of this
power plant so how do you decide let's
say you decide once a day in the morning
whether to turn it on or turn it off
right or not to turn it on
so how do you decide well sounds
complicated in reality is very simple
you wake up in the morning right you
look first of all at the newspaper and
find out what's the price of electricity
today and price of electricity you know
for each power sometimes for each 15
minutes it's determined so you know for
each hour or maybe the daily price
enough for the whole day so that's the
price that's if you sell it that's how
much money you will get on the other
hand to produce one megawatt-hour of
power you have to do something you have
to turn on your turbines so you have to
bring some fuel you have to put some
fuel into the your turbines just to make
them kind of move right I mean just and
produce the electricity fuel can be
anything let's say it's natural gas
right but
some of you now you'll have to determine
so you know how much money you'll get
for one megawatt hour of power right but
how much it will cost you to produce it
so how much fuel you need to determine
how much first of all how much cost in
terms of fuel to produce one
megawatt-hour
you have to know the efficiency of the
plant because the efficiency of the
plant is telling you how much units of
fuel we'll see how much mm BTUs so
millions British thermal units of
natural gas that's how its measured how
much mm BTUs of natural gas you have to
burn to produce one megawatt-hour well
this measure of efficiency for the power
plant is something called hit rate so
heat rate is exactly this coefficient
which you multiply the so if I say that
heat rate is seven it means that I need
seven mm BTUs of gas natural gas to
produce one megawatt-hour of power
that's all so for in our case there is
nothing to be concerned about it's just
simply the sum constant that is given so
it's some constant between seven to
twenty twenty it's a very inefficient
plant very early run seven is right now
more kind of a standard concept that's
the the constant correspondent to the
natural gas power plant which is right
now the majority of the new plant says
is the natural gas plant and there are
some other costs associated with
producing one megawatt hour and just I
don't know air conditioning labor cost
and so on and so forth right so we
typically they're not the biggest
component so if let's say this is seven
what is the price of natural gas right
now they remember
that's I wish but it's not it's around
four dollars right now let's say right
Paraiba to you so this so you need 28
dollars this probably around three
dollars so you need 31 dollars to
produce one megawatt-hour oh no not that
gasps sorry natural gas I'm talking
about
okay sorry about that I'm just but even
that even gasoline is right now around
five dollars yes or maybe you are
filling your tank some place which you
share with us so is that clear that's
basically so you wake up you look at the
price of the power let's say it's 50
dollars you know your plant is let's say
hitter 8 8 you look at the price of
natural gas it's $4 variable costs $3
will you run the plant yeah what will be
your profit so $4 8 3 so it's $35 - it
will cost you to produce one
megawatt-hour
this is $50 you made $15 profit you turn
it on it turns if on the other hand the
price of power will be $30 you look at
the newspaper you go back to sleep and
nothing happens you get 0 for the day so
this is maximum go to this price and
zero agreed
well now before I go to the next slide I
have two together we'll have to
determine what is if I want to buy a
plant all right if I want to buy a power
plant how much I'm willing to pay for
that
well what I willing to pay I know that
every day I'm getting this thing right
but I don't know each of these things is
a random number so I have to kind of buy
I have to construct the distribution of
this price of this price
maybe correlation between them it's a
two-dimensional distribution right so
correlation find some expected value and
that's how I will pay much I will want
to pay for the for the power plant right
so now we come to the interesting
question so now real work starts so I
know that this is the value that I have
to integrate but I don't know with
respect to which distribution so I have
to now construct the model of the power
prices fuel prices and then take this
two dimensional distribution and try to
find the expectation and that's how much
you're willing to pay for this power
plant agreed well so let's start with
kind of building these components right
I mean just that's what the again Kwan's
will do using already the experience
from other markets and so on you already
heard the other lectures right so what
would do we first look at the
distribution of power prices to see it
because I don't know how to model the
evolution of power prices I know if I
use simply Brownian motion let's say
it's my first idea well let's see
Brownian motion gives us the
distribution which is as remember at any
point of time it's kind of normally
distributed right if I if I look at the
terminal distribution of price after
which is driven by Brownian motion right
if I assume that the prices are driven
by Brownian motion then at the end I'll
get the normal distribution
so if I look at that say equity this is
S&P 500 indeed its we all know that S&P
has fat tails right but as you can see
in a moment this is not a fat tail I
mean just this is very close to the
normal distribution right from for the
equity guys of course for the guys who
trade the stocks
its enormous leaf fat tail but from the
commodity point of view this is just
perfect
normal distribution this is what the
decease is the distribution that we deal
with this is the the tails here are just
so normal distribution just out of the
window immediately right so Brownian
motion out of the window we cannot
construct this distribution of the
terminal prices of power using that
that's one thing so we have very fat
tails and this is the kind of the
parameters that specify this
distribution if I look at the let's say
the equity index the kurtosis is very
close to the kurtosis of the normal
distribution which is 3 but if I look at
the North Pole which is the spot prices
in Scandinavian countries kurtosis is 26
if I look at the one-hour price at 76 so
it is as you can see as as far from
normal as as possible we've seen it in
the picture and these are the numbers
correspond to that moreover look at the
behavior of the prices what this is the
price in some in Texas for example power
prices in Texas what immediately jumps
what I mean look at the price and say
wow how is it different from what you
see let's say in the equity world there
is stock market for example what is it
that immediately jumps at you what is
different here
go ahead and just there's no right or
wrong answer
spikes that's the keyword like no other
market if we have spikes here that's a
major major issue for us from the
modeling point of view you take any
standard with a Brownian motion it will
never exhibit the spikes not only that
the volatility of course in the of the
prices as we already expect is huge I
mean until hundreds S&P volatility right
now is ten percent this is hundred two
hundred sometimes thousand right
everything all the intuition you have
about the behavior of the prices a bit
your behavior of the random variables
right is mostly it was evolved all this
intuition under this ten fifteen twenty
percent volatility some random variables
behave a completely different way when
they are we have volatility of 100 or
200 to 300 percent so that's another
thing that will be challenging us we
just saw spikes and high volatility it's
just the same thing it's everywhere so I
just wanted to bring that it's a
different region of the country it will
be exactly the same thing so it's common
thing so if you look and try to
summarize what we're trying to capture
is mean reversion in spikes is more or
less the same thing so we now if we go
far away it will go back right high
kurtosis regime switching I will talk
about that in a moment
and non stationarity but just that's
goes without saying that's true for most
of the markets another problem that we
have to capture or another not the
problem but another phenomenon that they
have to capture that the power and the
fuel natural gas exhibit a very
particular term structural structure of
the correlation so correlation is not a
number it's it's depending on the heat
rate in the market
remember heat rate is the efficiency of
the power plant that Iran
the market depending on the efficiency
you may have very high correlation low
correlation we'll discuss that at the
end of this talk and we just fly this
cap but that's right now I'm giving you
something that we observe and our models
prefer the shipment should capture that
as well so i'm although requiring for a
model of pretty intense right let me
just and pretty difficult let me just I
don't think that you ever seen the
requirement that the correlation should
have some particular structure and just
depending on some parameters and so on
okay
any questions
so the models typically I mean first
thing people do or they take the models
that they know and they try to apply
let's just very quickly go sort of the
model I mean you've seen this models
already in the previous lectures right
let's start with the straightforward
geometric Brownian motion which out of
the window right away right I mean did
he agree because no spikes know how and
have no correlation structure nothing I
mean just so it's clear that in order to
we want to kind of start with brand
motion geometric Brownian motion try to
maybe modify it a little bit right so
what what is spike spike means that just
things go up and then they're pulled
back so there should be some mean
reversion right so minute version is
good right but unfortunately mean
reversion if you first of all it's
pretty strong so it goes remember the
price goes from thirty dollars two
thousand dollars and go back to thirty
dollars right and we just so Universal
should be extremely strong right second
of all what pushes it to the South
dollars level right you need to have a
jump right so that's why people
introduce the jumps so we have mini
version jumps jumps and mean reversion
still it is becoming pretty clear that
this will not work for the following
reason it goes from thirty dollars two
thousand dollars and then it goes back
because it's a spike it goes back within
three four days it comes back right so
the mean reversion should be extremely
strong the force of pulling backers
should be super strong but if it's so
strong that moves you back two thousand
four thousand to thirty imagine what it
does when you're on the level of thirty
dollars it just will be completely flat
right I mean just nothing you could not
move there right so people observe that
and introduced well they figure out
maybe the mean reversion will be
different at the level of thousand
dollars when you are the normal level of
thirty dollars right
the difference so you introduce right
now so called the regime switching so it
means that all the parameters change so
you introduce the kind of the high price
level low price level parameters change
and and now we're getting to the example
that we just we discussed in the first
half you end up with the model with ten
parameters twelve parameters which is
absolutely impossible to manage right I
mean I can give you another probably
hour of discussing why this approach
journal is is not good and then not just
in commodities but everywhere else
imagist I'm I'm not a big fan of making
the models extremely complicated because
one complexity introduction of one
complexity leads to introduction of
another complexity and you just cannot
manage this thing it's impossible to
manage theoretically it looks fantastic
unmanageable so we have to figure out
something else
so all this methodologies and I'll put
them there the methodologies people
actually use the stochastic volatility
the the regime switching multiple jumps
and so on this it's all used but it's
not what I want to suggest I want to
suggest something completely different
this is the methodologies that typically
are coming from fixed income I'm sorry
fixed income world or foreign exchange
or equities and so on I want to
introduce you something completely
different
any question so far so I want to
introduce the methodology which is more
suitable and more understandable from
the commodity point of view because
actually what's the price of commanded
the price of commodity is driven by only
two things can you guess which exactly
supply and demand that's all it is
that's what we'll try to do maybe we can
we have hard time modeling the commodity
prices using just these standard
methodologies from different markets
which rely only on the
prices themselves maybe if we introduced
some fundamental modeling as well I can
do it without losing the most important
part of this model is that matches the
market data so I have to a and we have I
want to model supply and demand but I
also would like to match every market
data that I have
so maybe I'm introducing completely
different complexity maybe not so let's
try to see if I am so if I can succeed
here not for before we go into the
school in the depths of this let's
discuss how the power prices are formed
while prices are formed in the following
way let's say that there are two
powerful market consists of two power
plants right and this generator one and
generator - every day they again price
prices of power formed at the auction so
every time the generators will submit
the bids which says the following
I can generate 50 megawatt
well the forgiven hour I've given I will
generate 50 megawatt if you ask me only
to generate 50 i will generate them at
$20
why because I will run my most efficient
power plant right which is the cheapest
one to run out generate 50 50 megawatts
if you want more if you want me to am
bidding if you want me to do 100 then
you'll have to pay me 25 because I will
have to introduce less efficient power
plants and so on 230 ends and if you
want to run me generate 600 you'll have
to pay me 50 so that's my bid so called
bid staggers that's that's what I'm
sending to the two dogs now the guy is
sending similar things the auctioneer
there is a training organization called
Independent System Operator ISO right
they collect all these bids they know
what demand will be tomorrow right they
collect and then knowing this demand
they will first of all they will sort
out all the bids in the most optimal way
so they'll put it all together by
sorting right so this is the auctioneer
combined all these two bids created this
graph so basically based on how much how
much they need to generate so based on
the demand this will be the price right
that will be the clearing price of the
market and then because auctioneer knows
all the beds the auctioneer
we'll send the demand for this generator
the generator you will generate 60 you
will generate 600 - whatever I
understand but and the final price is
the highest basically highest price that
is necessary to meet the demand so if
the demand is 600 so this will be the
price if it's 800 this will be the price
right so the the the price is clearly
the function of demand for any given day
right
well if this is the case then if I look
at the if I plot to the scatter plot
demand versus price I'll have to see
something different a substance similar
well let's see when we take a particular
market and do the scattered graph so
demand versus the price you see the
product this is the the graph that we
expect to see it's a little bit fat why
is it fat why is it not a straight line
why it's not the aligned as before but
it's fat what what is random here
remember the the I told you that the a
generator will bid approximately how
much it will cause them to generate at
that particular day right that course
depends on the fuel price and that is a
random number so what you can see here
is a lot of this curves but they are
kind of randomly moving because of the
fuel price affects the cost of running
but conceptually philosophically this is
exactly what we discussed that the these
guys will bid this this curve and
depending on the demand right the price
will be simply the value on that curve
are with me yeah
so far so good so this is that's what we
are trying to model so if we can model
that if I can model the for everyday the
bid curve that the auctioneer the
Independent System Operator sees I know
the price at that particular day
moreover I don't want to get too
complicated but in reality I don't even
have to know precisely the curve I kind
of have to know precisely the
distribution because remember for the
value of the option you don't need to
know where the price will be at
expiration you need to have you just
need to know how the price will be
distributed if you catch the
distribution correctly right through
again dynamic hedging and so on that's
what black Scholes tells you you can
actually value the option correctly so
you can value the power-plant correctly
but that's besides the point the point
is right now I'm trying to model somehow
this the randomness of this bit curve so
price so now to summarize the power
price is the function of what of demand
clearly we already notice that but also
the fuel prices because the fuel prices
determines the cost of generation
therefore how much a generator will bid
into the market right I mean that's
depending on the course if the natural
gas goes through the roof the price of
generating one megawatt will be very
high so the person will be the generator
will be bidding very high prices and
that's what we see here and also outages
we have to model out just because the
market is only finite kind of fleet of
the power plants and if a couple of them
will go down the price of power can be
affected dramatically the 1997 the
Indiana the price went from $40 to
$7,000
because tornado hit the nuclear plant
you take a big chunk of the generation
from the stack and all of a sudden
you have to run absolutely anything
including some very expensive diesels
and so on so the price of power
obviously goes very high okay so these
are three things that we'll try to model
so how we will model that well before
even I get to the modeling of them let
me just again outline our modeling
approach if I know the fuel right let's
say there are no outages if I know the
fuel then the fuel price I know then how
much each of the generator how much it
will cost for each of the generator in
the market because I know everybody in
the market right I know how much for
each of them it will cost to generate so
fuel if I know a fuel price I can
generate so called generation stack it
means the cost of generation for each of
the generator for each of the
participant in the market the outages
will simply allow me to take out some of
these participants out of the picture
basically right so I need to know that
but that's at any given day if I know
the outages I know the fuel prices I can
construct the cost of generating for
everybody so it's close to the beat
stack it's something that they will bid
right there course maybe plus some
profit I don't know what their profit
margins are but what I know I know the
the market prices I know the options got
the trade and so on so from the
generator so the beat stack will in
general follow the generation stack it
will be more or less the same thing
maybe some added profit requirements but
I will actually back this profit
requirement from the market prices so
that's where my supply demand approach
and the market will get together I will
adjust the generation stack in such a
way it may be moving and up and down in
such a way that our
matched the prices and they match the
option prices so measure the volatility
of the market so now the circle is
completely closed if I can succeed in
doing that questions this is the the key
right well let's see if I can do that so
first I want to sum now to if I manage
to do that then if I know how to model
the evolution of fuel prices I know how
the outages are modeled I can actually
model the demand then I can determine
how the power prices will be moving in
time so power price is the function of
the bid stack and demand as you remember
so if I know the defendant the evolution
of the bid stack evolution of the of the
demand I can determine the evolution of
the power prices completely different
approach so let's start with the
evolution of the fuel was building the
fuel model well I told you that there is
natural gas in reality we have to model
all that stuff because each of them has
a curve has a volatility it looks a lot
but in reality it's not because we have
a pretty good idea
unlike the power prices with the spikes
and all this crazy behavior we have a
pretty good idea this behavior of these
things because they're all storable term
by the way power prices are jumping
because of non stir ability of power
prices because they are not storable
because they are non storable right I
mean just you cannot smooth out the
changes in the demand right I mean just
so you have directions immediate these
are all storable commodities so their
behavior is much more regular they're
much closer also to the to the equity
prices and so on so we can use some
standard models so from the modeling
point of view they not particularly
difficult to model so particularly I
mean just natural gas heating oil and
fuel oil and we just the coal I'm
interested
we have a pretty good understanding how
these things outage well we take the
standard model from and this reliability
theory provides us with a very well
developed mechanism I mean apparatus how
to model these things I mean usually we
do it through some kind of post on a
version of Poisson process it is a very
well understood there's a lot of
literature that we can model that very
easily where do we have the parameters
for the for this person's the government
provides us with the there is a
government data sometimes we get it
directly from the from the power plants
everybody keeps track of the frequency
of the advantages and so on and so forth
demand how would will model demand well
will model demand through the
temperature typically why temperature
because for temperature we have a lot of
data it's statistically very stable
thing right so there are many different
approaches to modeling temperature it's
up to you there's a lot of literature so
I'm not going to go into detail so we
choose something we model temperature
from that will model the demand and
there it works pretty well so now we
have remodeled the evolution of
temperature evolution of demand
evolution of fuel evolution of the
outages now we can construct the
generation stack so for remember the
generation was this curve right this
curve that is was a function of demand
right but also the function of the
outages variable costs and and so on and
the the fuel the vector fuels right and
then there are this parameters alpha and
this alpha parameters we choose to match
the futures the forward curve for the
power prices and all other market
parameters as we need
so that's how we get so we imagine the
market and we're matching the we're
matching the kind of supply and demand
formations now it is very clear why was
this approach I can capture spikes
without effort without any effort and
the reason is very simple this is my
remember the stack my beats Deco
generation stack whatever so for for
high generation volumes it's becoming
more and more expensive to generate and
after certain time you exhausted all
your cheap plants you have to go to very
very expensive plants like diesel plants
and so on I'm adjust which runs maybe
once in the lifetime maybe once a year
twice a year and very expensive but they
determine the price they are the ones
that determined the clearing price at
the market now let's see if we're
somewhere here this is demand demand is
driven by temperature temperature is
typically a normal thing right which may
be mean reversion if it goes up but then
it's typically reverse reverses I mean
so this is the distribution of demand
around here well the demand moves left
to right and we just up down the prices
don't change much so that's your normal
regime but let's assume demand is
somewhere here right if you are to the
left of it the prices are very small but
the moment you move a little bit to the
right you temperature moves a little bit
to the coil region right
you immediately spike into the thousand
dollar territory but remember
temperatures mean reverting so within
five six days it comes back you go back
here your price goes from high levels
back to the normal level
that's your spikes right you get it
completely for free
and I'll show you right now
couple of graphs one is the actual graph
the other is the simulated using this
approach for the same market so as you
can see this is the actual price for
that particular period these are the
prices that we generate just plain Monte
Carlo simulation so you can see this can
be easily this right it's from the point
of view distribution of the spikes and
so on it's exactly the same thing this
is what we were after moreover I'll tell
you even more if I knew the path of the
fuel then obviously my approach there
are two graphs here they are not you
cannot distinguish between them because
I substituted exactly the right price of
the fuel I mean just actual price which
was historically and therefore my price
and the actual price were the same so
but in reality of course I don't know
the path but as I explained to you I
don't need to know I just need to know
the distribution of fuel prices is
correctly captured once I have the
correctly captured distribution of the
fuel prices
I have according to this correctly
captured distribution of the power
prices moreover so as you can see we
have a very nice behavior
now dip from the parameters point of
view this is the model look at the
kurtosis
this is summaries kurtosis of the model
and versa kurtosis of the empirical it's
very very miracle so distributions are
very close I mean just the skewness and
so on I mean just it's a very very good
good
capturing of the of the distribution so
this approach works very nicely right
it's completely different from what you
get used to but it's it's it's really
the one that works more of a final final
benefit right a bonus point this is
simulated correlation structure remember
and this is the actual one
very close and the beauty of it is that
you don't have it's not an input it's an
output I don't ever use the correlation
as an input in my model I got it I got
the distribution of power gorgeous fish
in a fuel natural gas put it all
together compute correlation and that's
what I've got and that means that this
is really a correct approach and I don't
need to put it I don't need to look for
the distribution that has this property
this property comes for free just as a
result of the completely alternative way
of modeling this thing now what is the
negative side of this the negative side
this is extremely difficult to do it and
maintain it because you have to maintain
the information of every power plant and
B was built was retired and we just will
be built and so on because you have to
look at the power prices 10 years 20
years from now you have to know what's
going to be there what kind of stack we
have to forecast that's a lot of
information to keep I mean you have to
have a big organization to work on that
to maintain it to build the model
because each region in this country has
a different market so you have to I mean
it's it's a massive undertaking it takes
years just it's not like you can get it
from the can it's expensive so I think
that will be good point for me to stop
if you have questions please let me know
questions
I think it's music to my ears
thank you